(mesmerizing instrumental music)
- I'm pleased, along
with the Graduate Council
to welcome Sir John Gurdon
as this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock lecture series.
As a condition of this bequest
we're obligated and happy
to tell you how the endowment
came to UC Berkeley,
so at the risk of some
repetition from yesterday,
it's a story that exemplifies
the many ways this campus
is linked to the history of
California and the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco during the Gold Rush
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley, as an expression
of his long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become
one of the most cherished
endowments of the
University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
So thank you Lillie and Charles,
and now I'd like to say a few
words about Sir John Gurdon.
We heard his impressive
list of honors yesterday
which included, from our
parochial United States
point of view, election
as a Foreign Associate
of the National Academy of
Sciences of the USA in 1980,
but I'd like to highlight some
of his many accomplishments
that led to this recognition.
Sir John will discuss today
his important experiments
that demonstrated
the constancy of the
genome through development.
In these he showed, for
example, that a skin cell
does not throw away the genes
to become muscle or nerve,
and so these experiments
showed that the nucleus
of a specialized cell,
if properly reprogrammed,
could support development
of a whole animal.
This really stressed
the need to understand
how genes were selectively
used, selectively transcribed.
His experiments using
this cloning in amphibians
really settled the scientific
question of whether
different animal cells
have the same genes or not,
and it remained not so
much a scientific question
but a technological
one of whether the same
would be true of mammals, but of course,
it took a couple of decades
before this was finally shown.
Following his experiments
in the '60s and early '70s
on cloning of amphibians,
his work became important
to molecular biologists
through his demonstration
that purified messenger RNAs
were very efficiently expressed
after they'd been injected
into frog oocytes.
This ability to produce correctly
processed and sorted proteins
from a very limited
amount of messenger RNA
was very important in the
early days of biotechnology,
and if one looks at the methods,
actions of some of those
early biotech papers,
you usually find that the
ability to assay and therefore
to clone these important
genes, such as interferons,
depended on Sir John's
observations that the oocyte,
the spherical test tube as
it's sometimes referred to,
was very effective in
expressing these RNAs.
These experiments with oocytes and eggs
were extended by Sir John to
study the expression of genes.
With Don Brown, he showed
that purified animal genes,
first the 5S genes, even before
the advent of DNA cloning,
and later protein-coding
genes were correctly expressed
when injected into
oocytes as purified DNA.
This stressed again that the
signals that control expression
must be directly encoded
by the DNA sequence.
As we heard yesterday, Sir
John has gone on to study
the logic of developing embryos,
how signaling factors are distributed
and interpreted to guide cell fates.
In recent years, he's also
returned, as we shall hear,
to the question of how
proteins in the egg cell
are able to reprogram specialized nuclei.
As we know, there are
plenty of experiments
that can be done in biology,
but if one's to discern some
sort of formula for success
from Sir John's example,
I'd say it's twofold.
First of all, he's directly
involved in the experiments,
working at the bench with a
small group of colleagues.
Secondly, he's got an extraordinary focus
on what's interesting and important,
and though this may not lead,
as he mentioned yesterday,
to five lectures on the
history of paintbrushes,
it does lead him to
avoid working on things
that are feasible but
ultimately not that interesting.
He continually asks
himself and his colleagues,
"What is the most important
experiment to be done now?",
and also, "What is the most interesting
"possible outcome from this experiment?".
Of course, the corollary of the latter
is that if the best possible
result is not that interesting,
then one should move on to do something
that is more interesting.
So it's a tremendous
honor to welcome Sir John
to give the second of
his Hitchcock lectures.
(audience applauds)
- So, thank you Richard for
your very kind introduction
and indeed, thank you
for coming back today,
very robust of you those
who were here yesterday
to hear the second stage
of this presentation,
and today the computer
seems to be willing to work.
Now this very dim picture
and it might help to have
the lights down a bit,
they get better than this,
I should hasten to say,
shows that, I talked
yesterday about how an egg
makes an embryo, a fetus
and finally an adult
and so you go from an egg to
a range of specialized cells,
for example, blood and skin.
And I mentioned that,
in the case of mammals,
this remarkable option exists
of taking cells from the early embryo,
and they are called embryonic
stem cells, ES cells,
and they can then be
put back into an embryo,
so you again have a route
to specialized cells
through that particular variant.
Now today I want to go back again,
starting from specialized cells,
and this red arrow shows
that we can go right back
to the beginning again, back to the embryo
and then follow through
these various routes
until you, again, get back to the adult
and this time you have
different kinds of cells,
for example, muscle and nerve.
So in effect you can derive
these kinds of cells,
muscle and nerve, from
completely different cells
such as blood or skin,
and that's the sense in which
you go from egg to adult,
and adult back to the embryo again.
And the real point of this,
at the practical level,
is to achieve cell replacement
without immunosuppression,
you know that if you receive
cells from someone else
you will be unable to
continue to accept those cells
without immunosuppression which
is a serious disadvantage,
and I'm going to be talking about
this route in that direction,
but I should say that these
experiments, like many others,
started with a purely scientific question
which Richard has clearly annunciated,
that is, whether all cells of
the body have the same genes?
Now the concept of
replacement is not novel,
and this picture dating from 1495
shows that there were two
saints, Cosmas and Damian,
who, if you can hopefully
see it better than I can,
are replacing the leg
of an individual here,
there's the spare leg,
curiously color-coded, and,
(audience laughs)
interestingly helped by two
technicians who had wings
which I hope was helpful
in the particular case.
Unfortunately, this
experiment has not proved
to be reproducible, and we
have to think of other routes.
Now there are a number of ways round this
and this is just to tell you
what the four points I'm
going to try and cover,
I'll be talking a bit about
replacement and regeneration
versus the remarkable
stability that cells have,
then I'll talk a bit about stem cells
from adults and embryos,
then about nuclear reprogramming
with a view to therapeutic cloning,
and then I'll say at
the end something about
the ethical concerns that
may exist in this field.
Now these, to some extent,
we get normal replacement
and these deer have these amazing antlers
which can actually weigh
as much as 70, 80 pounds
and they are regrown every year
in a matter of three months,
so there's an extraordinary
ability, in some cases,
for enormous amount of
proliferation and replacement.
And indeed, in ourselves
we replace our blood cells
at an amazing rate, indeed,
you may be alarmed to hear
that by the time I finished
you will have destroyed
something like 100 million blood cells,
happily they'll be replaced.
But then some of the parts
of our body are not replaced,
for example, the lens your born with
essentially stays throughout your life,
and other parts of the pancreas
and so on are not replaced,
so that leads on to the question
of whether we have an
ability to regenerate
parts of the body that
have been lost or removed.
Now this particular
question also goes back
a remarkable time in history,
and this quotation comes from Hesiod
which was written at about the
time of Homer, about 700 BC,
and the only bit that we need
to concern ourselves with
is the bit in yellow and
you'll see that it reads
that the liver, I can't really
look here, became immortal
and indeed it grew to the
same extent every night
as during the day the
long-winged bird, the eagle,
et that liver.
Now that's a remarkable discovery,
and it happens to be true,
that if liver is removed
it regrows to the same
extent as the amount lost,
now how Hesiod discovered that in 750 BC
is quite obscure to me but it
makes the interesting point
that that fundamental principle
somehow seemed to be known at that time.
Excuse me.
Now, moving on a lot, we now know that
in the particular case of
the salamanders or newts
there is this remarkable
regenerative ability,
so if you cut the arm
off at the forearm level,
in the course of some days
that will completely regrow,
as it also will if you cut
it off at the arm level,
it knows how to regrow the same amount,
so that regenerative ability does exist,
but we have to remember
that when that happens
there is really no evidence
that the cells which
replace the missing part have
actually changed in type,
so when you get new muscle and new bone,
the almost certain explanation is
that the new muscle and
bone comes, in fact, from
the preceding muscle and bone
which was already in place,
so there's no change of cell,
in effect, you can only hope
to replace the kind of cell
that was already present before.
Now the next thing I'm
going to talk about now
is the stability of cell differentiation,
and we're asking the question of whether
cells can change their
state of differentiation.
Now the only really good test of this
is to take one single cell
and to transplant it into
the wrong environment,
you put the cell in among other cells
that are not of its own kind,
and that's because many
experiments in this field
have involved moving
whole pieces of tissue,
large groups of cells, to
another site, and of course,
those cells are largely
surrounded by their own kind,
and so you don't really test whether
a cell is stable in its differentiation
because it may mean that
it simply goes on doing
what it was doing in the first place
because it's surrounded by similar cells.
So you need a different kind of test
and this is the one that
I think is compelling.
So in this experiment,
there's an early embryo
and the red bit indicates cells
which were destined to become muscle,
they hadn't become muscle at that point
but that's what they were
going to do in development
if they'd been left there.
So these cells are taken out
and separated into single
cells, and one single cell
is then implanted into
another part of the embryo,
in fact, the bit that's
going to form the gut.
Now when you grow that up,
and in this case it forms
an amphibian tadpole,
this cell now finds itself
still as a single cell inside the gut,
and the question is, what
does it do about that,
does it change its mind or does it not?
And the result is that it does not,
and this is the actual experiment,
that is the implanted cell,
you can barely see it but
it's labeled with a fluorescent
marker so you can follow it,
and this is the cells
that normally form muscle
with an antibody marker, and
there is that single cell,
the cell that had intended
to become a muscle cell,
and indeed, it still
does become a muscle cell
even though it is still
sitting inside the gut.
And this makes the important point
that these cells take a decision
remarkable early in life,
really within a day of development,
as to what they're going to become
and even though they haven't become,
they haven't followed that route yet,
they know what they're going to become
and they won't change their
mind, and generally speaking,
that is true of differentiated cells,
cells on the pathway to differentiation,
they simply will not change
their mind to a different fate
as long as you keep the whole cell intact.
And there are other
experiments of this sort
that show that even earlier
than in this experiment,
cells have made up their
mind and won't change fate.
Now one explanation for
that is the following,
and that would be that,
in this diagram of a cell,
the nucleus expresses genes
and the messenger RNA
goes into the cytoplasm,
makes protein, and some of that protein
goes back into the nucleus
and reprograms that genome
to express the same genes,
so when this cell divides
into two daughters
this cyclic reprogramming
ensures that the cells continue
to follow the program that
they have already embarked on,
that's the simple way of explaining
why it is that cells enter a pathway
and are extremely reluctant
to change their mind.
We'll come back to that in a minute,
but I now want to turn to
this question of stem cells
in both adults and in embryos.
Of course, what we'd like
to do is to get stem cells
out of our various tissues
and use them for replacement,
but they're actually very hard to find,
and I should just explain quickly
what we mean by a stem cell.
So here is a cell, and
a stem cell is defined
as one which can do two things,
it can either reproduce itself,
go on continually dividing,
making more cells of its own kind,
or it can enter a differentiation pathway,
so in this case it divides
and one of the daughters
follows the differentiation pathway,
becoming, for example, a
nerve cell or muscle cell,
the other one remains a stem cell,
and in the course of time
that one will divide again
and one of its daughters
will go off and specialize
and the other one remain a stem cell,
so that's what we really
mean by a stem cell.
Now people have been looking
very hard for these stem cells,
and I show this quite complicated
picture from Elaine Fuchs
where she was looking for
stem cells that recreate skin,
our skin reproduces pretty well,
and the point of it is
that the actual stem cells
are essentially
indistinguishable from others,
tucked away in a little corner,
almost impossible to find
unless you use a battery of markers,
and only with great difficulty
can one identify them at all,
and even if you have, to get
them out is more difficult,
and even when you have,
they almost never seem
to change fate and become
something entirely different,
so that's one of the
problems of stem cells.
Now there's an interesting experiment
I'm going to mention now by Helen Blau
where, what was done in this
case was to take patients,
human patients, which were suffering
from a hematological disorder, cancer,
and to try to alleviate their condition
they gave them bone marrow grafts,
and in some cases the bone marrow cells
were taken from males rather than females.
In the course of time,
these patients passed on
and they were able to
look at the brain cells,
in particular, these Purkinje cells
which are rather recognizable,
and they could tell whether
derivatives of the bone
marrow had entered the brain.
In fact, that happened,
though not frequently,
in fact, they scored some
tens of thousands of cells
and I think they found four which showed
derivatives of the bone
marrow in the brain,
and this was shown by using markers,
the green arrow up there
points to a little spot,
and that is an indication of genes
which are on the Y chromosome
and they're from the male contributor,
the red one is the female chromosome.
It showed that, in some
cases, bone marrow cells
could actually contribute and
become part of brain cells,
and that's remarkable,
one has to say however,
that it was an extremely
rare event, and in fact,
this was a fusion and it
doesn't actually tell you
that the bone marrow cell was
making any useful contribution
to the Purkinje cell of the brain,
it could be that it fused there
and the Purkinje cell didn't
mind, it just accepted this
and without really making
any difference to it.
So that argues that this kind of idea
of bone marrow stem cells may exist
and there may be cells in the bone marrow
which can follow a whole
range of different options,
but it has yet to be shown
that this would really be a useful route
and that it would be in any
way therapeutically useful.
Well now we move on to
embryonic stem cells,
and this is a remarkable field,
and it started with people,
Stevens and Pierce discovering
that there are things
called teratocarcinomas,
these are really cancers
which proliferate extensively
and they often form a whole
chaotic range of cell types,
you can see, can hardly read it from here
but there you can see, I think,
on the picture, hopefully,
that erythrocytes blood is
formed, keratinocytes, top right,
connective tissue, cartilage, bone,
a whole range of cell types
really chaotically arranged.
Now the remarkable thing about those cells
is that they could be
transplanted into hosts,
and in some cases, they
made perfectly normal cells,
they even gave up their
cancerous condition.
Now that was the background
to remarkable experiments
of Martin Evans in 1981
when he really discovered
that you can do the following experiment.
You start with a mouse
embryo making the early,
there's the zygote, the fertilized egg
and then it makes the blastocyst,
it's a bunch of about 200 cells containing
the future embryo ones
called inner cell mass there,
of course, if you leave
the embryo it will make
whatever it would, mice or humans,
and you can take these cells
and put them in culture
where, amazingly, they go on
growing almost indefinitely.
And then what you can
do is take these cells
and implant them into a host
embryo, another kind of embryo,
when they will differentiate
into the whole range of cells,
every cell you can imagine,
it's a truly remarkable
phenomenon and to this day,
we really do not know what
these embryonic stem cells
really are in a mouse,
there's no evidence that a
mouse has any such cells,
nevertheless, when you
take these cells out,
they will grow in culture
and they have this really
extraordinary ability
to differentiate into many directions,
really a kind of ideal stem cell.
And in recent years this
has now been done in humans,
this is a human embryo, the
blastocyst and inner cell mass
and you can, with some difficulty,
people have been able
to grow these in culture
and some of them will
remain undifferentiated,
and other ones will begin to differentiate
in different directions.
Now this is potentially
a very valuable method,
and a huge amount of work
is being done at the moment
to try to find ways of getting
a homogenous differentiation
of these cells,
they tend, again, to make
a rather chaotic collection
of different kinds of cells,
so I'm not going to pursue that,
except to just summarize these points.
So these embryonic stem cells
have many remarkable advantages,
they have a capacity for almost
indefinite proliferation,
they have multipotent differentiation,
you can make them into
everything including germ cells,
and you can freeze the stocks.
Now the disadvantages
seem to be the following,
they do tend to undergo genetic changes,
those who work with them
will realize that after time,
the stock has undergone various changes
so they don't really remain
exactly how they were in the first place.
It's hard to make them
make some cell types,
notably things like pancreas,
it's extremely difficult
to get them to go in that direction,
they go very easily into
the nerve direction,
neural direction.
And lastly, if all this works perfectly,
there is still the problem
of immunorejection,
and what that means is
that when you hope to
give a patient cells of this kind,
they will be rejected by the
normal rejection mechanism
unless the patient is immunosuppressed.
Now that's not a good thing
to be if you can avoid it
because you get all the
infections that are around,
and as a matter of fact
it considerably increases
the probability of these
cells becoming cancerous,
so that's not an ideal route
but no doubt one that will be followed
and will turn out to be
progressively, I think, very useful.
But I would like to now
follow the other route
that we particularly are interested in,
and that's to do with
nuclear reprogramming
and therapeutic cloning, as we call it.
So, first of all, what is
the question we're asking?
And what we're trying to ask is whether,
we say, can we make
rejuvenated embryonic cells
from adult cells, and I
mean, of the same individual?
Now if you could do that,
you would avoid the need,
I'm sorry about the spelling,
it says immunosuppression not
needed, it should have said,
means you would avoid that
because if you can have
embryonic cells of your
own genetic constitution
you would not have to be immunosuppressed.
And the principle of this route
is the nuclear transfer route
which has been mentioned by Richard,
and the idea is the following.
That you start with an egg,
and I'm going for a while
to talk about frog eggs
where this all started,
but the principles are the
same for mice and humans,
so you start with this egg
and you actually use
ultraviolet irradiation
to kill the female pronucleus,
the egg chromosome,
so it's cytoplasm with no nucleus,
and then you pick up a
single cell in a micropipette
in such a way that the cell wall is broken
but the nucleus is not damaged,
and then you inject that broken cell,
but with a protected
nucleus into this egg,
where it essentially substitutes
for the egg and the sperm
that normally enter that egg,
and then you get a ball of
cells and eventually an adult.
Now, this is the principle of cloning
because each time you do that,
you start with the nucleus
of a cell from an individual
and you get a whole range of individuals
which are genetically identical,
cloning as it's now called.
This is not itself a novel situation
and this picture, which
may seem wholly irrelevant,
is actually a picture of a forest
with bracken growing
throughout this forest,
and you may or may not
know that bracken in forest
is essentially one plant,
it's all been produced vegetatively so
actually every bit of this
bracken is all part of a clone.
But in animals that doesn't work,
and we have to follow this
other route that I've mentioned
where you have to be rather careful
in taking up a cell into
a special micropipette,
this has been specially
forged under the microscope
with an exceedingly sharp hypodermic tip
and a smooth orifice there
for the cell to go in
because you have to break the cell wall
but definitely not disturb
the nucleus inside the cell,
and part of the skill is to
make these special instruments,
which of course is all
done under a microscope
and then to inject the nucleus
into the cell in such a way
that you don't damage the egg
and hence the reason for this sharp point.
So there is the pipette
and it's just grabbed hold of the cell
and it's going to, it's a
very old film or video indeed
so I apologize for the condition,
if you watch very carefully,
you'll see something move up there,
we'll see it later better,
that in fact is a bubble of air
which you have to put in the
micropipette in order to decide
when the cell at the end has
been injected into the egg,
of course, the inside of
the egg is also invisible
because of the pigmentation.
So this egg has now received
the transplanted nucleus
and in a moment it will start
dividing into a two-cell,
in real life, that takes
about an hour and a half,
and here we see a sample of them,
now that one's going pretty well,
that's got a two-cell, as has that,
and that's just now gone
into the four-cell stage.
These ones didn't work
and that does happen
in a certain number of cases for reasons
we don't understand, it just doesn't work.
Now that one's getting on quite well,
it's a good eight-cell,
and I think in a moment we'll
take a look at one such one,
here is one of this kind,
it's beginning to divide,
and these divisions
occur rather frequently,
about every half hour in this species,
much slower in mice and humans.
Now in this case you get a typical result
where the cells on one side
are dividing very well,
in fact, if you look very carefully
you'll probably see there's a,
this wave of division
starts at about that point,
it'll suddenly send a wave of
division through the embryo
and then it'll wait about half an hour,
and then another one will start
and go right through the
embryo making these cells,
essentially dividing the embryo
into large numbers of cells.
Now you'll notice that in this case
there is no such division,
that's a very common result
of transplanting nuclei
from specialized tissues where
they weren't ready to divide.
What you then do is to take
these cells, the good cells,
separate them again, and we'll
see this happen in a moment
and then you retransplant and here we are,
there's the pipette, that's
the air bubble marker,
this broken cell has gone in the end,
this will now go into an egg,
and we may see the
bubble marker move down,
I think it's going to do it
in a moment, there it goes,
and pushing the nucleus,
you hope, inside the egg
which will then now be able
to divide completely normally,
that's a perfectly good four-cell embryo,
and it will divide just about
as well as normal embryos do,
partly because the nucleus has now been,
to some extent, rejuvenated
and brought back to thinking
that it's a nucleus of a
normal embryo in its cell.
So that's how these things work
and we may wait for just a moment or two
to see this division going on,
these cells dividing very fast,
again, there's a wave of
mitosis starting at one end
and working through the embryo.
Now this one is completely divided,
all the cells are dividing in unison,
and that's the kind of one
which will normally make a
perfectly normal individual,
it's got a few thousand
cells at this point,
so that's how the thing works.
Now, just going quickly over the history,
Briggs and King first
did these experiments
and they found that by the
fairly early embryonic stage
they got no normal development.
We happen to use Xenopus where,
although the success rate
goes down, you do, in fact,
get a number of embryos going
through entirely normally
and this was, I was lucky enough
to get this in as a graduate student,
the first entirely normal adult animal
in the vertebrates obtained by cloning,
so this was taken from a gut cell nucleus
and it makes this frog which was,
actually lived to 20 years,
pretty good for frogs,
and it laid eggs and everything else,
and you can make clones this way.
This is an albino donor,
that's to say, embryo
that had the white pigmentation,
was used to supply nuclei
and that's why all these clonal progeny,
which are males and
therefore small, are white,
even though they have come
from eggs of the dark female
so that's the basic idea of cloning.
Now let me quickly go through the issue
of whether this still works
for specialized cells,
here is a tadpole with muscle,
and you can take a single muscle cell out,
that's the nucleus, this is a muscle fiber
going right the way
down through that cell,
transplant that nucleus to eggs
and you get, essentially, normal tadpoles,
here's one from the nuclear transplant,
that from the control, and
when you look, for example,
at the eye of such a
nuclear transplant tadpole
it's actually entirely
normal, lens, retina,
but all these cells have a
nucleus that was originally part,
in this particular case,
of an intestine cell,
so the reprogramming does happen.
The success rate is quite small,
to get normal adult
fertile frogs, about 1%,
many of them form these partial embryos
of just the kind that
we've seen on that video.
Now you can use those, here's one,
you can take cells from this part directly
and graft them into a host,
like we might do for
cell rescue experiments,
there's the graft,
happens to be GFP-labeled,
and here are now the green cells
derived from the intestine nucleus
that are parts of perfectly normal muscle,
each one of those is a normal muscle cell,
derived however, from the
nucleus of an intestine cell.
So that procedure works
rather well, you'll get,
so for example, if you
start with intestine
you can get muscle and nerve
by these various maneuvers
in something like 30% of the cases.
And the main point I
need to make now is that,
as I said at the beginning,
when you transfer whole cells
from one part of an embryo to another,
there is no possibility whatever
of getting a reprogramming
or switch from, say,
intestine to muscle or nerve,
but once you take the
nucleus out of that cell,
then by nuclear transfer you
get something like 35% of them
will switch fate completely
to this new direction.
So that's the principle
of nuclear transfer,
and the conclusion is that the nuclei
of some differentiated
cells are totipotent,
you can get fertile adults, for example,
from the nuclei of intestine cells,
functional muscle and nerve from intestine
comes with a relatively high
frequency of about a third,
and the fundamental point is that there is
a conservation of the genome
during cell differentiation,
indeed if that weren't so,
the whole idea of cloning could not apply.
And now finally, as was mentioned,
this has been done in mammals
with the famous Dolly the sheep,
this works remarkably
well and refinements,
particularly by the Jaenisch
lab have actually been able
to go through with a
genetically deficient mouse,
do, through nuclear
transfer, gene correction
and finally rescue the
animal by this route,
so it's really a considerable
achievement and shows,
I think, the future direction
for this kind of work.
So the conclusions so far
are that some transplanted
somatic cell nuclei,
I'm sorry, I can see what's happened,
I'm just going to go back a step now,
let me just take a couple
of minutes on this point,
it's a slightly complicated point
which I'm only going to
spend two or three minutes on
and a number of people
will not follow this but,
for the connoisseurs,
they might be interested.
The curious recent discovery is this,
that if you start with nuclei
from the specialized cell,
transplant the nucleus
and take them into the wrong germline,
like the intestine to neuroectoderm,
about half of the nuclei
actually show a memory
of the gene expression they had before,
likewise if you start with
the neuroectoderm nuclei,
transplant them with several divisions
and take them into the endoderm,
most of them, nevertheless remember that
they were originally going
to be neuroectoderm cells
and they express such a marker,
it's a surprising result,
and indeed, you can carry that on for
a whole another generation,
so that for 30-cell divisions,
some nuclei remember their fate.
And so the conclusion from this
is that some transplanted
somatic cell nuclei
show a long term memory
of an active gene state,
and this may account for some cases
of abnormal embryo development,
because we do need to explain why it is
that only about a third of
these nuclear transfers work
and that seems to be one
important explanation for that.
We don't know the basis of
this remarkable phenomenon
but it may well have to do
with the epigenetic marks
placed on cells such as the
association of histone H3.3
being amazingly persistent.
So that little commentary on the side
leads me to the last
part of the talk where
I want to talk about mechanisms
of nuclear reprogramming.
Now the reason we want to know about this
is that in the far distant future,
I'm sure long after my time,
it should, in principle, be
possible to take a skin cell
and to overexpress, in that cell,
those genes which are needed
to reprogram that cell
back to an embryonic condition
without even having to go through an egg,
that's the long term aim,
but in order to achieve that
we have to know what are the mechanisms
by which these nuclei are reprogrammed
once you take them out
and put them into an egg?
So I'm going to talk briefly now
about the cells that we call oocytes,
these are the forming
egg cells from the ovary,
and they contain an amazing
structure, which is this,
inside that cell and it's
called a germinal vesicle,
and it's a very specialized nucleus
containing a large amount of material
which is needed by the
embryo for development.
Now these cells contain
amazing chromosomes
called lampbrush chromosomes,
the most transcripts
in the active chromosome
that's ever been discovered,
huge number of genes are
transcribed enormously fast,
so these oocytes are used
to get a direct switch
of a nucleus from one kind
of gene expression to another
without any replication or
cell division in between,
it's a very kind of ideal
cell in which to observe
and hence analyze this remarkable switch
or reprogramming of gene expression.
And I would say there are three things
we need to do to understand
this, eventually,
one is the reversal of epigenetic changes,
I'll mention that in a moment,
we have to understand the
supply of transcription factors,
and what I call chromatin decondensation
which has to do with making
these genes accessible.
Now, we found out recently that
you can take mouse fibers out of nuclei,
put them into the oocytes
and you turn on this stem
cell gene called Oct4,
it's a very important
gene for making stem cells
behave as such, so you can see the genes
strongly activated a
few days after transfer.
The gene that these cells had
on before is extinguished,
that's inherited message,
and so it means that you
can, slightly surprisingly,
use frog oocytes to
reprogram mammalian nuclei,
that's an extremely useful thing
because of the huge abundance
of these frog materials.
Now, looking at just
going quickly over this,
one direction is that we find
that one of the key events
is this removal of the methylation state,
the mark in these
specialized simus nuclei,
this particular diagram
connoisseurs would appreciate
shows the removal of methyl groups
from the promoter region of Oct4,
it's a very important step
in this reprogramming.
This happens, oocytes can do it,
and most other cells,
very few other cells can,
and we're really trying
very hard to find out
what is the mechanism in the molecules
that reverse the process
of this specialization?
Step two involves the recognition
of transcription factors
and this rather complicated diagram shows
the bit of the Oct4 gene,
the promoter region,
to which a number of
proteins are known to bind.
Now this, because of the huge
amount of material available,
you can hope to find proteins that bind
to these regions of that promoter gene,
and in making this point I should say that
we have something like
a million-fold advantage
in using frog material rather
than mouse, or even worse,
human material to find out how
these genes are reprogrammed,
and that's because one frog
egg is 4,000 times bigger
than a mouse or human egg,
and one frog contains 25,000 such oocytes,
so it's a great thing and
I'll mention this again,
to choose your material
favorably, that's that root.
And lastly, this thing of decondensation
is rather remarkable, these
are actually mammalian nuclei
inside this germinal
vesicle of the oocyte,
and you will see that these enlarge,
that they've gone from a small thing
to this really large inflated object,
about a 10 to 20-fold expansion,
and that is probably critical
in enabling the genes needed
for the turning on of these
stem cell marker genes,
the reprogramming, to actually work.
We have to try to find out what that is,
and one way of doing this is to find
that if you take the
proteins off these nuclei
before you transplant them,
you accelerate the rate of reprogramming,
leading possibly to a way of finding out
how to identify the
reprogramming components.
So that's really all I want to say on the,
what you might say, the scientific side,
but I've left myself,
I hope, a few minutes
to touch on this question
of what we call ethics.
Now, you'll know that there are objections
to what science can do by some people,
and I've been quite interested
in talking to a number of people,
particularly religious people,
people in the priesthood,
about this whole issue
because I'm interested
in why they should think, if they do,
that science isn't the best way forward,
and as far as I can diagnose,
there are five reasons
why people have reservations
about this work,
and these are the five.
So one of them says, it's what I call
the thin end of the wedge
argument, and they say,
"Well, we don't mind
your putting mouse nuclei
"into frog oocytes, who worries about that
"but what next will you
do, and so we better
"stop this thing quickly
before it gets out of hand".
I find that a somewhat
unconvincing argument
because, for example, if you
really wanted to save lives
you would ban all transport,
all cars and transportation
but we don't choose to do
that, there's always an element
of disadvantage to most advantages,
so I'm not persuaded by
that type of argument,
a rather tiresome one because
it's not very specific.
The second argument is, the
whole thing is unnatural,
well of course, that's
not a very good argument
because nearly everybody
will use antibiotics,
which are themselves unnatural and so,
if you're really going to
object to this kind of work
on that ground, you should
not use antibiotics.
Third argument I've heard
is that God intends humans to suffer,
now that's an interesting thought
but if you read the Bible,
you will observe that there
are a number of stories
which are miracles, now to me,
the bottom line of a miracle
is to relieve suffering,
they all seem to come out that way,
people get better, not worse,
and so I would say that
that's not what God intends,
at least as adjudged from the Bible.
Fourth reason is the
killing of a potential life
and I think that's one that
is particularly prevalent
among people who object, now
their argument runs as follows.
They will say that if
you take, for example,
the nucleus of a skin cell of you or me
and put that into an enucleated egg,
you will obtain an embryo,
and indeed you will.
They say that is now a
potential human being
and you should not be killing
that potential human being
in order to make life a bit better
for yourself, is for yourselves,
that seems to be the
essence of the argument.
I find that an inappropriate argument
for the following reason,
that when you have mammalian
embryos, mouse or human,
there is in my view no
possibility whatever
that they can form an individual,
and that's because of the
process of implantation.
Embryos which can be made,
they'll develop quite well
in a test tube but unless
they are implanted,
there is absolutely no
possibility, to my knowledge,
that they could ever
progress beyond that stage,
and therefore the argument
is that these early embryos
are not, in fact, potential human beings
in any sense at all, so I would
disagree with that argument.
And the last argument I heard was this,
which was, again, rather
surprising to me, people said,
"Well it's good for us to see
"how others tolerate
suffering", in my view,
a rather selfish view because
they're saying we admire,
as one does, people who put
up with great discomfort,
they themselves not
having that discomfort,
and therefore if we
cured all these problems,
we wouldn't have the benefit of seeing
how people put up with these things,
slightly surprisingly
that came from someone
in the priesthood so, that
was that level of argument.
Well, as you can see, I'm
pretty biased on these things
but I, I thought I'd not
like to miss the opportunity
of making these points.
So that's what I wanted to
say on the ethical side,
but let me finish with one comment
and I don't know whether we could have
the lights up for a moment,
it would be easier if I
can see who I'm talking to.
You may, people often say to me,
I feel I'm not heard without this thing,
people often say to me,
"Why do you use frogs?",
I've talked about frogs a lot and,
"Why don't you do all these
experiments with humans
"or if not humans, at least mice,
"this is a completely
inappropriate way forward".
Now my view is that science
has progressed very largely
by people choosing the right material,
and I was very impressed
when I read the account
by Levi-Montalcini and
Cohen of their discovery
of growth factors, the nerve growth factor
and you may or may not know this story
but it's something like this.
They discovered that there is material
which makes nerves grow
extraordinarily actively
in Hamburger's lab a long time
ago, and so they pursued this
and finally they obtained
an extract of material
which had some nerve
growth-promoting activity.
So Cohen decided, very logically,
that he must find out
what is in this extract,
so he thought well, the first thing to do
is to see if it contains nucleic acid,
so we will remove the nucleic acid.
Now, in those days, a long time ago,
one way to do that was
to make use of a thing
called snake venom phosphodiesterase,
so he did the logical experiment
and added the phosphodiesterase,
thinking this might destroy the extract,
actually what it did
was to make the extract
enormously more active,
completely what he wouldn't have expected.
Now, many would have said,
"Well, that's a bad
experiment, forget that",
but he then said, "Well that's amazing,
"it must mean there's something
in the extract other than
"its DNA destroying activity
which is important",
so he thought, where do I get this from?
Now, this came from snake venom,
not an easy source of material to collect,
bucket loads of snake venom,
so he then logically said,
"Well, what is the snake
venom-producing gland?".
This turned out to be a thing
called the submaxillary gland,
so he then said, "Well now
let's look at rats or mice
"or something that we can get a lot of
"and make extracts of
the submaxillary gland",
which he did and finally
purified the growth factor.
So I find that a very interesting story
and it shows that it
really is best, in my view,
to work with the most favorable material,
even if it's not what you expected,
to find what you're looking for
and then of course you
can go back, as he did,
and find out if that factor
from the snake venom,
the submaxillary gland,
was actually the nerve
growth-promoting factor,
and that's, in fact, what happened.
So, I like to persuade the people
who I hope will continue
to give me funding
that frog oocytes actually
do have something to offer
because of this extraordinary
abundance of material.
So, let me just finish,
I'm just gonna summarize
this at some little length
and then I'll have a
little take home message
for those who find this rather
tiresome to read all this.
So, what I said is that,
reading from the top,
regeneration in vertebrates
is really very poor,
and the differentiated states
of cells is extremely stable,
the cells really do like
to stay where they are.
Second one says that adult stem cells
are very hard to obtain,
embryonic stem cells
proliferate and differentiate
but this would require
immunosuppression of the recipient.
We then said that nuclear transfer
establishes the
conservation of the genome,
and reprograms nuclei back
to an embryonic state,
and the fact is that this
kind of reproductive training
is subject to a lot of errors
and is generally accepted,
I think, by all scientists to
be inappropriate for humans.
The fourth one says that
nuclear reprogramming
requires reversal of
differentiation marks,
transcription factor supply,
chromatin decondensation
and, in my view, is potentially valuable,
indeed, for the possibility
of cell replacement
or therapeutic cloning.
And you've seen that I
have rather firm views
on ethical concerns not being important.
So, for the bottom line,
the people who don't
want to follow all this,
I always have a final
thought, and this is this,
it says, what can be done
usually will be done, in time!
So, where something is possible,
scientists find better ways of doing it,
and in my modest view,
there will eventually
be useful cell replacement
through this route.
And finally, the colleagues of mine
whose work I've referred to
is Henrietta Standley, the
single cell transplants,
nuclear reprogramming,
graduate student James Byrne,
Stina Simonsson, and all
these are graduate students
who have helped a lot in this work.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(mesmerizing instrumental music)